أجنبي
[موسيقى]
أتمنى أن تكون قد ربطت حزام الأمان الخاص بك في
الألبوم أو الأغنية التي تفضلها أثناء القيادة،
اعتمادًا على حالتي المزاجية، لدي
قائمة تشغيل كلاسيكية لبرونو مارس، ثم
حصلت على ما يحدث أيضًا  هناك، فأنا
أحب الموسيقى الكلاسيكية
إذا كنت أريد حقًا أن أهدأ
ولكني سمعت أن الأشخاص الذين يستمعون
إلى الموسيقى الكلاسيكية غريبون بعض الشيء
ربما أنا غريب بعض الشيء، لا أعتقد
أنك غريب
لذلك علينا أن نتحدث عن ماكس هومر،
صحيح لا لقد انتشر الأمر على نطاق واسع، نعم، لقد
عرفت ماكس لفترة طويلة، إنه
رجل رائع، ومن الواضح أنني أردت أن ألعب
أفضل ما يمكنه لعبه، وكان
دائمًا داعمًا جدًا لرياضة
الجولف للسيدات  وأنا أقدر حقًا أن
لدينا الفيلم الوثائقي Netflix PGA Tour الذي
سيصدر قريبًا، ما
رأيك في هذا النوع من الأفلام الوثائقية
التي تتيح الوصول إلى جميع مناطق الجولف
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه من المثير للاهتمام دائمًا رؤية ما
وراء الكواليس  فضولي
حقًا، كثير من الناس لديهم فضول، ولهذا السبب
يعمل Netflix، أه برنامج الواقع
يعمل لسبب أنني لست معجبًا كبيرًا
ولكني متأكد من أن المعجبين يمكنهم رؤية
الكثير من الأشياء خلف الكواليس التي
لا يرونها  سأرى لذلك أعتقد أنها ستحظى
بشعبية بالنسبة
لحفلة ديموغرافية أجنبية خلابة معينة، حسنًا، ما
رأيك أنها رائعة بصراحة، أحب عندما يكون
اللون الخوخي بهذا اللون الأزرق
أشعر وكأنني في إحدى الجزر،
لذا كان عام 2022  من الواضح أنها سنة صعبة بالنسبة
لك بسبب مشاكلك الصحية، كيف
تفكر في ذلك العام، أعتقد أن 22 عامًا كان
عامًا هائلاً للغاية بالنسبة لي
[موسيقى]
كان لدي الكثير من الأشياء المختلفة التي حدثت على
المستوى المهني والشخصي ولكنني
تعلمت نوعًا ما  الكثير منه
وكان ذلك نوعًا ما في العام الأخير من
العشرينات وأنا سعيد حقًا بتركه
ورائي وأشعر
أنني سأتعلم
أشياء جديدة وأكتشف نفسي مرة أخرى عندما أكون في
الثلاثينيات من عمري الآن 30 عامًا  لقد كان
عامًا مثيرًا للاهتمام للغاية،
لكنني أردت نوعًا ما أن أكون أكثر
اتساقًا هذا العام وأعتقد أن هذا
ما أسعى لتحقيقه
[موسيقى]